a fennel sausage patata the exciting
thing about Fattah so is the fact
there's no set recipe because it's
basically eggs whatever else you have
left for me the secret of a good starter
is in the sausage nice hot pan onions in
getting this on the onions heat nice and
high season fennel seeds we give the
onions a really nice flavor everyone's
used to cooking sausages whole but it's
a really nice way of using them take
them out of their thin skin we're gonna
do is crumple all that wonderful spicy
fennel sausage into the onions it's
gonna release all that flavor a lot
quicker pretty important to do that
gasps nice and high and the longer you
can rise the sausage the more flavor
you gonna gain
six whole eggs give me eggs a really
good mix flat leaf parsley a staple in
Italian cooking chop it quite rough some
parmesan look it's a really nice
seasoning
fresh pepper and touch of salt
get in there when you fall through it so
when you slice it no one's complaining
they've got less sausage gonna make it
even more Italian by topping it with
some buffalo mozzarella dry it and then
slice it nice and thinly twist it
mozzarella in and then finally finish it
with that Parmesan cheese
I get the top just as tasty as it is the
bottom my frittata needs
three-and-a-half to four minutes under a
red-hot grill to achieve the best
results always ensure your oven or grill
are preheated to the perfect temperature
this is the thing I love about Italian
cooking it's about sharing but always
focusing on the ingredients look at that
I mean it's incredible a little shake
the pan to make sure all comes out and
then spatula underneath I just leave it
it's light fluffy and it smells
incredible
that for me is a dream come true this
amazing how far you can take six eggs
and two sausages Wow
spicy fennel sausage frittata my
ultimate Italian breakfast it's a
cracking start to the day
[Music]